Jojo Jojo Jojo I'm like yes girl yeah
[Music]
you're not fooling anyone Abbi we know
that you and dodo used to bump heads on
and off camera you've yelled at her
scolded her and made her cry yet somehow
you've managed to stay in contact with
the sea was in fact some might even call
you friends in the end dojo is super
grateful for the opportunities you gave
her so she's willing to put the past
behind her now if that isn't star
quality we don't know what is joe-joe
with the bow bow is one of the most
beloved dance film stars of all time but
it isn't her personality that got her
where she is today
it's her many talents keep watching to
find out why Jojo is the most talented
star on Dance Moms
like many famous dancers Jojo started
performing when she was only two years
old and there was always something about
her that stood out amongst the other
contestants Jojo was filled with energy
everywhere she goes she brings a certain
enthusiasm to her dances making it hard
to look away she's a natural performer
who loves being on stage and she knows
how to captivate her audience clearly
Jojo was destined for the limelight if
there's one thing that such Jojo apart
its how connected she is to the music
she isn't a soft and graceful dancer
through and through but more of an
energetic dancer who matches every
single beat with attitude Jojo has
musicality for days which allows her to
connect the choreography on a deeper
level and that sort of talent doesn't go
unnoticed by the judges judge while most
dancers aim to be grateful Jojo aims to
be remembered but to do this she has to
offer something different than what
we're used to Jojo has managed to
cultivate her very own dancing style
which is borderline aggressive at times
but so much fun to watch while some of
the other Dance Moms stars faded into
the background
dojo always gave a hundred and ten
percent securing her spot on the team
the 16 year old is such a hard worker
she's on fire every dancer has their
strengths and weaknesses it's nearly
impossible to find someone who has the
full package lyrical dances just aren't
JoJo's cup of tea
but if there's one thing no one can beat
her at its turning
Jojo is a master turner and evidently
steals the show every time she twirls
around staying perfectly balanced and
graceful isn't an easy thing to do which
proves the extent of JoJo's talents but
what's cool about Jojo is that her
talents weren't limited to dancing
despite dedicating most of her
upbringing to competitive dance
Jojo actually excels in languages and
learning did you know that Jojo knows
how to speak Korean or that she has a
photographic memory making it easy for
her to memorize scripts on the spot well
now you do having a photographic memory
probably makes last-second
choreographies a breeze when it comes to
Jojo style some might say that it's a
little out there but in the end dojo and
her mom know just what to do to sell an
image Jojo branded herself with des
lunes help which led her to making a
handsome revenue they had a vision and
they saw it through Jesslyn made sure
that her daughter wore handmade bows in
her hair which turned JoJo's bows into a
total bad clearly the see was did very
well for themselves now that we've
covered the bow craze of 2017 let's get
back to the dance floor Jojo has always
had a knack for performing jazz-funk
numbers her entire demeanor changes when
she starts performing them when it comes
to jazz spunk Jojo can perform a solo
duet or a group number like it's
nobody's business we loved watching Jojo
take on a jazz funk number alongside
Mackenzie Ziegler Bren rom fallow and
Kelly grace Jojo and Abby Lee Miller
have had a very special relationship at
first Abby couldn't get over how rude
Jojo was and continuously scolded her
but that never brought Jojo spirits down
for too long in the end
Jojo knows how to take constructive
criticism but that doesn't mean that she
won't clap back say what you will about
the C was but they brought something
fresh and exciting to dance moms there's
no denying that Jojo is a skilled dancer
but she's so much more than that
for one she's sort of a fashion icon
although we must say her style is very
unique and unpredictable when it comes
to JoJo's clothes the more glitter the
better she loves wearing bold colors
that's Sparkle from a mile away
Jojo might be a modern celebrity but she
won't hesitate to strap on a pair of
glittery and pointy shoulder pads you
could even say that Jojo style matches
her loud personality to the tee
like it's some crazy it's awesome but
what makes Jojo stand out and stay
current is her knack for social media
Jojo never lets too many days go by
before connecting with her fans she
posts daily vlogs online as well as
pictures on her Instagram page she may
only be 16 years old but she's got 8.7
million followers on Instagram and 10.2
million subscribers on YouTube despite
only appearing for a few seasons of
Dance Moms Jojo has a net worth of 10
million dollars so yeah she sure knows
what she's doing it's easy to see that
JoJo's tiwa is the most talented Dance
Moms star of all time
she's mega famous but she doesn't let
that get to her head she's a role model
through and through and a good one at
that
is Jojo your favorite Dance Moms star or
do you think she's overrated sound off
in the comments and that's a wrap
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things we'll see you next
time
[Music]